[Music]
I'm Frank Eva I'm a computational
biologist in the plasmodium team it's
part of the malaria program at the
Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute I use
computer programming to design DNA
vectors that can manipulate genes and
malaria parasites a vector is a DNA
molecule that we use to manipulate the
genome of the parasite in a specific way
we can delete a gene we can modify a
gene to do something else
we can change the way it's been used by
the parasite when we knock out a gene we
don't just delete the gene we need to
replace it with something we bring in a
little package of DNA that conveys new
function to the mutant cell who called a
resistance marker the resistance markers
are guided into the right place in the
malaria genome by short DNA sequences
called illegal nucleotides the design
software identifies the best
oligonucleotides for each individual
gene once the software is designed
oligonucleotides aid will produce order
sheets for them which will be sent to
external companies to actually produce
the oligonucleotides once we receive
these custom-made oligonucleotides the
lab base stage of the process begins
this has many steps and takes about two
weeks firstly the oligonucleotides are
mixed with template DNA and a PCR
reaction is performed now each well
contains DNA fragments with the same
resistance marker genes known as a
resistance cassette but the ends of
these fragments differ and those will
later guide the finish vector to
specific target gene in the parasite
these ends are the oligonucleotides we
designed earlier next a crucial step
called recombination happens in bacteria
each of these four Tyrael cultures
harbor a specific short piece of malaria
DNA that contains an individual target
gene identified at the design stage the
product of the earlier PCR reaction is
then shot into these bacterial cells
using an electric oration machine under
specific culture conditions the cells
now perform the recovering reaction
which replaces a piece of malaria DNA
with the resistance cassette when
exposed to antibiotics due to the
resistance marker only the bacterial
cells that have performed this reaction
correctly will survive we now need to
replace the bacterial resistance genes
for a new malaria specific asset that
will allow us to eventually select for
successful vectors in the malaria
parasite for this would first extract
the modified DNA known as plasmids from
a selected bacteria we then perform a so
called gateway reaction to swap one
cassette for another
the modified plasmid is put back into
bacteria using electroporation again and
then plate it up once the bacteria have
grown on the plates we pick the colonies
and culture them overnight as a first
quality control step we run another PCR
reaction to confirm that the genomic
fragment is correctly modified we then
run the products on a gel and record the
results for our sample tracking database
once we know the DNA modification has
worked the bacteria are stored in
freezers the bacteria now contain the
final vectors that are ready to modify
the genome of malaria parasites we make
these available to a worldwide community
of scientists through our website and
also use them for large scale
experiments of our own working at scale
is very different from performing a few
individual reactions in the lab even at
the relatively modest scale of the small
malaria genome procedures need to be
highly optimized and standardized and
you need to think about tracking the
process through the lab good
communication between team members is
very important when you produce at scale
any mistakes made also quickly multiply
and may cost a lot of time and money to
rectify I joined the project at an early
stage when it wasn't a scared of
pipeline yet it was great to see the
progress from a few bespoke constructs
to a sizeable scale we recently
published an important piece of work
that probes half of the genome for the
role of genes and growth of the parasite
in the blood and it's great to see all
that work culminating in a new
scientific discovery
[Applause]
[Music]
you